there is an arms race afoot but there's
so much to celebrate i mean if you just
look at
the uh number of meditation apps and
mindfulness apps and
the millions and millions of people that
are practicing
these techniques now something you've
been talking about your entire life that
date back
millennia have reached a certain tipping
point where
the mainstream has gotten onto these and
they're seeing benefits and that is a
trigger point or a catalyst for
greater uh spiritual growth and and
exploration
and expansion in so many other areas
like just get people
to sit for 20 minutes use whatever app
it is whatever gets you to do it
and you're suddenly on a very different
gentle and gradual journey but
distinct from whatever it is you were
doing before we see it in
our food choices with the proliferation
of plant-based
options now and the advent of all of
these
dairy and meat analogs and now the cell
biology that's creating these cultured
meat products that i think are going to
revolutionize how we think about our
our daily meal and will soon put us in a
position where the idea of slaughtering
animals for food will just seem
absolutely
as barbaric as it actually is correct
think about the the
downstream or upstream whichever way you
want to look at it
repercussions of all of this suddenly
we're not going to need to cut down
forests for
grazing land and that's going to improve
the climate circumstance on earth
there's so many
beneficial byproducts of this
movement that you're describing this
plant-based movement
and a lot of people
are thinking about putting plant-based
existence
to a test in their own life that would
never have thought of it before
simply because the pandemic has caused
people to be
a little more sedentary because there's
not all
you know you can't all get out and do
what you have to do
and in that way eating the heavier foods
you know the more fat filled foods has
caused a lot of people
sugar-filled to put on a lot of weight
yeah
and so people are going wow how can i
change this
through my consumption other people are
saying well have you heard of this and
have you heard of that
i mean you you go to the to the grocery
store now
and you see i mean just a common grocery
store
and you see all kinds of things that say
vegan
that say plant-based
that is a sign of the beginning
of the movement that you and i are
praying for
that allows us to make the shift
from the military industrial
complex to more
the agra human
humanitarian complex in which
we eat food that's food we have
relationships that are not canoes
that both people can stand up and they
won't capsize
and all of a sudden you look 100 years
downstream and that's why i feel
very strongly about what you know i'm
working on you look a hundred years
downstream
and it looks like wow can you believe
what we went through as opposed to
wow this is getting worse and worse
i do wonder whether it can be
accomplished through incremental change
though because
while recognizing these
movements and the progress that's been
made the clock
is ticking and these these advances in
consciousness and in technology
etc seem to be in lockstep with this
march towards
you know ecological destruction that we
as a human race
seem intent upon and i wonder
whether we can achieve
the symbiotic balance with the planet
that we aspire to have and that we
actually
must achieve if we want to perpetuate
the species and
the species with whom we share the
planet in the current construct
of a capitalistic
democratic republic because
capitalism by its very nature does
operate with this zero-sum
game you know competition uh
construct that
is it that that by its very nature is
somewhat can be characterized as
predatory and and really isn't
simpatica with a symbiotic relationship
with
the planet and as we see these advances
they become
they become armaments in
in the toolbox of of capitalism they
co-opt them
and use them and these are good things
on some level
but ultimately are we not
blind to the bigger picture like do we
need to have
more of a revolution in order to
save the planet and survive
your comment i wonder
is the stimulant i wonder comes from the
root of i wander
when when we wonder we wander
off the path and in that
wondering or wandering we end up
finding things that were not
available or obvious to us
in the path of that industrial
capital democratic etc
where it was just going in lockstep into
a dismal future because it was starting
to undo
itself a lot of people
wondering will cause a lot of people
wandering outside of normal and the
pandemic was a really good catalyst for
that as well
and the revolution that i see coming is
either going to be a climatic
crisis in which everyone has to scramble
on equal footing or
it's going to be that incremental stage
in which we are
able to and i hate using this because as
you know i love
frogs but there's the there's the
metaphor cliche
of boiling the frog if you raise the
temperature a tiny bit a tiny bit a tiny
bit
the frog doesn't jump out of the pot so
please forgive me
frogs of the universe because i didn't
mean to bring that up
however it does make a it does make the
point
and the point is that incremental
changes
may be safe enough to the powers that
are holding on
to the competitive combative capital
industrial
military complex and the zero-sum
economics
is nowhere in the future the zero-sum
of debt and asset is nowhere in the
future
the future is found in the hidden life
of trees which is the book about
the economic system of the forest
and that economic system of the forest
is where there's a need the need will be
met because the need has a supply that
will meet it
and we have the same thing holding true
in the world today
more food is thrown out because of
blemishes
than is needed to feed the starving
across the planet
all someone would have to do is
mastermind the way in which the
distribution system connected everything
together
that kind of economic system the kind of
spiritual religious system that doesn't
compete with each other
the kind of political system that
doesn't have one side competing and
combating with the other side
the kind of economic system that is is
shareable and and and sustainable
these are the ways of the future and to
get there
we will either go incrementally and if
that
isn't going to work climate's going to
change the case
and climate is going to bring about the
revolution and the revolution is not
going to be
in my estimate and don't don't think
that i'm the one that's saying this is
how it is and there's no other way
but in my in my view of things
the only way that that climate is going
to change us
is the way the pandemic changes us
changed us
and that is that a significant series of
disasters
suddenly wakes up the wakeable
and and those who can't be awakened
continue to try to struggle in the way
they are begin to learn from those who
are waking up
and finding a new way in the new
environment to have life
in a sustainable manner and that's why i
say
for me it's a 50-year plan it's not it's
not a decade's plan it's not an election
cycle plan it's not any of these things
it's a it's a long range plan
and if each one of us keeps doing what
we're doing
that is positive and beneficial
i believe that that we come out
and i won't say on top because that
maintains the hierarchy
i believe that we come out in a common
existence
always the hopeful optimist
[Music]
you